we're in taiwan we're back with a
three-part mini-series joining us on all
of our episodes our friend translator
fellow buzzfeed producer and glenn
tape
we're seeing some great modes of
transportation some fun games some
tricks some treats and some delights you
know how you know we're in taiwan the
beautiful 101 tower and because it's
steamy which is perfect for the first
food that we're doing in our trip
dumplings
a food that's often cooked with steam
great transition today i'm worth it
we're going to be trying three dumplings
at three drastically different price
points to find out which one is the most
worth it at its price i am so excited to
do dumplings so excited i feel like
we've been talking about this episode
since season one one of my goals this
trip is to brush up on my mandarin
because i have the mandarin skills of a
four-year-old
my goal is to get it to a five-year-old
by the end of this trip that's a very
good goal thank you dumpling number one
we're going to see miss liu in her
restaurant
little just raisin ball how's
we're gonna get some 50
cent
pan fried dumplings and we have our head
of price so low and worth it no we
haven't that is a drastic price point
you've been making dumplings for 30
years i'm just curious what you think
makes a perfect dumpling
what types of buns do you serve here
well manchester bien the sao pai jose
[Laughter]
we've heard that the dough of your buns
is very delicious what makes it so
special
how many should we have
you're going to stunk it
you know how you're actually in taiwan
how
dumplings and motor scooter sounds it's
a beautiful noise so not only are we
having dumplings but we're also having
soy milk so we notice you're actually
making your own soy milk here and tell
us about how you guys make that
change
cheers
i didn't know that's what soy milk is
supposed to taste like kind of like a
peanut butter drink like that's how
nutty it tastes to me okay how's the soy
milk like almost done oh my goodness i
really like the soy milk this is really
good it's like the first time i had
full fat milk oh yeah yeah you know adam
try some soy milk
yeah let's get to the buns let's get to
the buns pork
cabbage
chive look at the bottom crust it's like
a little hi i'm crispy
the dough is so good what was the term
for
chewy that an actual term yeah this is
so cute
i don't know how to describe the weight
of it but it's pleasantly plump
pleasantly plump okay the pork bun
oh
whoa
that's my favorite adam you want to take
a bite
you know my problem with burgers
you're playing a game of like jenga
tetris as you're biting into it with a
bun you're not losing anything lastly
the cabbage i love the shape of this one
it looks like a clam this is 50 cents we
just ate three dollars of food by the
way
okay this one might actually be my
favorite damn it
i don't live in taiwan 50 cents i don't
even have to be hungry it's just it
would be foolish not to the pleasure you
get out of chewing really good bro
yeah oh my gosh q q
q
i think you need to open this in america
i can give you my dress just open up
shop next to me because i need to eat
this on my way to work please
that was a dumpling it was actually a
bow but bell is a dumpling uq is my new
favorite food terminology it's uh quite
warm here in taiwan so i think before we
have our next dumpling we need a
refreshing treat we're in taiwan what
kind of treats should we have shaved ice
we're going to showa ice the chinese
name is
bingsu
bing
this looks awesome this is one of your
favorite desserts right not this
specifically but shaved icing generally
so there's two types of shaved ice here
classic mango chunks on top of milk
shaved ice and then chocolate shaved ice
with whiskey it's really good but it
tastes really different
i'm going full mango
oh wow
this texture is very surprising oh
the mango
inka get in here try this mango this is
like garden of eden mango right here
you're so sweet
of course it tastes good you drink
whiskey with ice yeah and chocolate
chocolate works we're eating a food
that's cooked with steam
and now we're eating ice so we're just
exploring all the meals and they call
that states of matter how many chemicals
in the room oh excuse me
all right
give me a fact dumpling fact it's not a
dumpling bag
it's related to dumplings though
definitely related fast dumpling wood in
fact because most foods humans eat are
soft the body and brain have learned to
like the novelty of an opposing texture
like crunch even after all that effort
to make a perfectly qq dough
it's still worth it to add the crunch on
the bottom back to the perfect food man
all right we're off to our next dumpling
spot we're gonna go see mr chen his
steam dumpling restaurant inca what's
the name of it ding haunts the ninja
[Music]
[Music]
how many dumplings do you think your
restaurant makes per day woman eating
[Music]
when customers come here are they only
eating dumplings or they ordering other
things as well
so we should order a few more things as
well sure
that's right
[Music]
we've built out our meal with some extra
stuff here we have let's dumpling it up
they make 5 000 of these a literal army
of dumplings in one day feels like i'm
fighting an army of dumplings with my
mouth foam
dip
[Music]
that's incredible oh wow dumplings i've
had in the past once it's steamed it
becomes loose around the filling yeah
but these are tight and dense and still
juicy inside so juicy let's do a side
dish break i vote century egg tofu
madness yeah
[Music]
okay
wow
[Music]
wow that's not what i was gonna do wow
okay oh okay wow
you know what i realized yeah egg
nature's dumpling
wow
cheers cheers
200 years
hmm oh yeah hold that up hold that up
yeah that's this is egg and you can see
through it it's very jelly
all right so here we have the vegetable
dumpling
watching them make these dumplings was
like magic they close their hands and
when they open it there's a dumpling
it's really like someone's doing a card
trick in front of your eyes fun fact
this is actually inca's grandmother's
suggestion
really yeah my grandma was the one who
recommended this place to me good
recommendation it's so cute
think about the amount of work that's
put into these dumplings and how cheap
it is that is the ultimate magic trick
that pork dumpling like a korean spa
like a dry cleaned shirt steamed to
perfection our next dumpling is also
going to be steamed we're having the
soup dumpling the shalom bao
that's right but before we do that we're
going to have another taiwanese dessert
treat
pineapple cake it's one of my oh my god
it's one of my favorite places
[Music]
so every time you come here even if you
don't buy anything they will give this
to you like a pineapple cake with oolong
tea that's confidence that's like we
know how good it is because you're
definitely going to get it yes and you
will cheers
cheers
[Music]
long
golly pineapple cakes are really good
buttery and flaky on the outside and
then you get that really fresh pineapple
sweetness and tartness iconic iconic new
york and cheesecakes taiwan and
pineapple cake yes yes something like
that smell it
[Music]
right um okay i see
i got it yeah i've never had pineapple
jammified like this should just pop the
rest well you might want to save to
enjoy it while you listen to this
dumpling fact
i'm sorry
what is fact in mandarin oh could you
say dumpling fact
doesn't andrew do the language better
yeah
yeah
in 2013 and 2014 chef turned writer
christopher st cavish created a soup
dumpling index measuring the thickness
of the dough the soup volume and the
total weight of each individual xiaolong
bao at 52 different restaurants this
data was then calculated with the
formula filling plus soup divided by
thickness of skin times 100 to assign a
score representing the quality of
structural engineering in jalan bao look
quadratic formula was already hard
enough all right next up we're going to
a superstar
a soup dumpling spot in taifong we're
gonna meet the boss man mr young it
originated here in taiwan they right now
at this very moment have 164 locations
worldwide that's at this moment that's
wild by tomorrow then it may be 180. we
don't know we're gonna go eat their
truffle
soup dumpling
truffle have you had it before not
truffle i'm not bougie
i'm just gonna walk away from that
comment
[Music]
how do you get the soup inside the
dumpling yeah
this is the tahoe ipa
it's locally brewed and it has a really
strong flavor of fruits oh the logo is
great it's a tiger cheers steven cheers
[Music]
that's quite good almost cider
so then for the pork chalong bao the
most important part is the soup inside
it's sort of like the soul of the
shaolin bell so we lift it up from the
top we place it at the back sorry the
bottom just sagged down at a very
satisfying
a little hole inside to let the broth
come out
and then please take a sip away from me
or just eat alone okay great i'm
following instructions stephen mmm
nice yes nice and we can add a little
bit of ginger with the sauce on top and
then you can enjoy the shallow together
all right wait for you to drink your
yeah i'm not good at how did you poke
that so well
would you need some help
[Music]
oh yeah yeah that's really good it's
almost cloth like the bottom fabric
the broth has like a sweetness to it
it's so good do people ever eat it in
one bite
yes they do but please be careful
because it's really hot okay sometimes
you just gotta fly too close to the sun
though so i feel like i want to feel it
burst in my mouth
it was hot
we mentioned it so much in this video
but i really have to bring you back to
the qq even though the dough is so thin
it still is very satisfying how do you
attain that kind of texture in like a
film sheet adam can you try this please
that's good yeah it's really good this
is our truffle and pork xiao long bao
why do a truffle soup dumpling
house
is
[Music]
before we get into the eating i do have
to point out the pleating on each
dumpling they're beautiful
oh yes
[Music]
oh
what
bougie cheers
these are awesome okay last season we
ate soup that had truffle in it we
learned that has to be activated by heat
and fat right so the truffle in a soup
dumpling
totally makes sense it really says
something about this dough that even
though it's still thin you still get
that qq it's impossibly thin uh common
complaint about our show is that we
always just put truffle on stuff to make
it more expensive and we see you comment
section
we see you but these are about three us
dollars per dumpling which is expensive
but for the taste of truffle how nice
this is i'd say that's worth it
show title watch out
the doing truffle right yeah they're not
doing it wrong
adam you want to see if they're doing it
right
so we're here at rauha night market
because inka suggested that we come and
eat their stinky tofu the smell around
the stall is quite stinky but once it's
fried it is much more subdued cheers
steven cheers
[Music]
so juicy
holy crap speaking of soup dumpling
that's a soup tofu try stinky tofu okay
so before we get to our worth it winners
what was your favorite thing in this
episode that was not a dumpling my
favorite thing was the fire hydrant soy
milk
at the lyoja shuejan bao place the
visuals of that are just astounding my
favorite thing was getting dressed like
a scientist at din tai fung central
kitchen we went through this airlock
that blew all the dust and hair off of
us and we got to see some really cool
behind the scenes stuff so stephen which
dumpling was the most worth it to you at
its given price my worth at winner today
goes to the pan fried dumplings at leo
joshua jambao the value was incredible
there the dumplings were amazing the
cabbage bun at that location was very
nearly my worth at winter but i have to
give it to the steamed pork dumplings at
location too like my fantasy of a
dumpling is that dumpling inca who's
your with a winner
[Music]
i don't know
it's so hard i want to say two because
it's my grandma's favorite but i think
it's honestly one annie
adam says his winner's din tai fung next
week
soup that's right soup again so soon you
say trust us
taiwan may be the perfect place to have
soup yes
so excited there's so many soups we have
so many soups it's gonna be great
so many soups
[Music]
[Music]
you